voici l'une des rares photos de l'homme
qui a terrorisé pendant des mois
l'algérie et la france l' émir du gia
djamel zitouni de son vrai nom abou
abderrahmane amin
il a commencé sa carrière comme militant
du fils en janvier 92 après l'annulation
des élections législatives en algérie il
est arrêté le front islamique du salut
est officiellement dissous dit unis
s'enfoncent dans la clandestinité en
hector 94 il prend la direction du jeu
il ya dès lors il multiplie les actes
anti français le 24 décembre sur
l'aéroport d'alger un commando du gia
détour d'un airbus d'air france
l'opération se solde par la mort des
preneurs d'otages djamel zitouni jurera
de venger leurs morts six mois plus tard
une série d'attentats secoue la france
en plein été bilan huit morts 300
blessés les poseurs de bombes étaient
les envoyés de l'émir du gia
le dernier geste anti français de djamel
zitouni précipitera sa perte
en mai le gia enlève sept moines
trappistes français en algérie
un mois plus tard c'est djamel zitouni
qui signe le communiqué revendiquant
leur mort le fils condamne zitouni et
isolé au sein de son propre mouvement le
14 juillet un communiqué du gia annoncé
son éviction deux jours plus tard djamel
zitouni tombés dans une embuscade en
algérie